it was the proposal that went completely
viral
it's not every day you get engaged on
stage with Beyonce such is the live for
bees dance captain and former single
lady Ashley Everett congratulations on
your engagement
yeah you look truly shocked I didn't
know and I was just trying not to
embarrass myself in front of all those
people in the live audience and then
everyone with their phones and cameras
right
when you put a ring on it and John's
actually here to true bring him in here
and I yeah I mean first of all you know
proposals are popping off at Adele's
concert left her fiance she runs a tight
ship yeah how'd you pull it off it's
funny because I actually have the ring
three months before and they finally
call me maybe like two or three weeks
before that and we got some room for you
so if you want to do this let's do it
I'm like absolutely let me talk to coax
and say yo you have to do with more
single ladies and of course the Creator
just been offered a week and then I
finally got back to be and she was like
okay yeah right we did get a moment with
her to say thank you and seven she was
offensive happy for you guys
congratulations she of course has a very
enviable relationship long relationship
adjacent is she operating advice as you
guys kind of lead into this next chapter
um we haven't really had a moment yes
okay JJ saw her and he was mean sorry
but y'all congratulations so you can
kind of tell her that they're really
like yeah yeah he passed me him along
he's like good press this is Jake I
heard you give great advice you know
what I have no advice because I haven't
seen
you